on
il est à peu près inconnu du grand
public mais il est un intime du monde de
la musique du classique au canada à 91
ans noël spinelli grand admirateur
d'opéra et de puccini en particulier
écoute encore régulièrement madame
butterfly sur son ordinateur
[Musique]
la caisse votre moralité emea la chine
et vous êtes un monsieur sa voix parce
que vous avez fondé son entrée en cavale
depuis 42 ans
les concerts la chaîne
c'est une de ses réalisations les plus
importantes est sans doute la plus
emblématique de son engagement
la création des concerts gratuits de la
chine avait pour but de rendre la
musique classique accessible au plus
grand nombre ses atouts pour partager
cette passion je me dis jamais tu donc
sont aussi fous moigne à musique qui
n'ont pas la partie noter que j'ai eu il
a la cote la réponse je la connais c'est
oui une autre grande réalisation de noël
spinelli la restauration de l'orgue
casavant de l'église des saints anges à
la chine
je veux son instrument qui répond bien
petit qui est extraordinaire
noël spinelli a présidé un comité de
financement qui a réussi à amasser plus
d'un million de dollars pour faire
revivre cet instrument centenaire de
qualité et de renommée internationale
c'est notre levier
c'était la personne qui nous motivait à
aller plus loin et à se surpasser ne
peut faire bouger le pont simple pour
l'essai avec ses projets john grew
ex-doyen de la faculté de musique de
l'université mcgill
grand spécialiste mondial d'orgue a
réussi à mettre sur pied le concours
international d'orgue du canada qui fait
aujourd'hui autorité dans le monde grâce
à la détermination de noël spinelli s'il
ne pas accepter jeu après deux ans de
discuter ça je lâchais ce grâce à noël
que ça existe je peux dire ça
noël spinelli fils d'immigrants italiens
a repris l'entreprise familiale et l'a
fait grandement fructifier il a choisi
le monde des affaires
il avait pourtant opté au départ pour
des études au conservatoire de musique
qu'il avait ensuite mené un début de
carrière de crooner dans les cabarets de
montréal au cours des années 1950 mais
son côté entrepreneur et organisateur a
pris le dessus et il a mis au service de
la musique
j'avais une réputation le livrer la
marchandise
c'est comme ça quand on peut bâtir une
réputation avec noël sicpa donne je vais
essayer de convaincre ses vient partager
mon rêve de beauté plutôt que d'essayer
de te convaincre
de deux je suis donné de l'argent si
nicole richard thorpe considère noël
spinelli comme un véritable mentor à
cause de ses grandes qualités humaines
et de son engagement à long terme dans
ses projets
c'est pas les gosses et pas une
célébrité une renommée s'est
véritablement pour aider aider le milieu
aider les jeunes de la relève
moi j'accepte ce prix renate chaîne pour
le bénévolat dans les arts je me réjouis
qu'on le connaît les bénévoles et moi
j'accepte plus là parce que je veux le
partager avec ses centaines de bénévoles
qui ont travaillé avec moi à travers les
années
[Musique]